arabes et juifs se disputent la terre
[Musique]
promise 1947 au lendemain de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale l'immigration juive
s'intensifie en Palestine considérée
comme la Terre Sainte dans la religion
judaïque la tension monte entre Juifs et
Arabes les attentats se multiplient la
région qui est alors sous mandat
britannique est dans l'impasse Londres
tente alors de réguler l'immigration qui
est soumise à des quotas en 20 plus de
7000 Juifs parqués près de fagoue
attendent là que leur sort soit réglé en
même temps que celui de la Palestine
venu de toute l'Europe pour trouver un
peu de paix en Terre promise refoulé en
y arrivant aujourd'hui parqué derrière
des barbelés il continue
[Musique]
d'espéré complètement débordé le
Royaume-Uni fait alors appel à la toute
nouvelle organisation des Nations Unies
pour régler le problème le 29 novembre
1947 l'Assemblée des Nations Unies
adopte un plan de partage de la
Palestine en TR de états autonomes Juifs
et Arabes et Jérusalem sous contrôle
[Musique]
international l'ONU a décidé de découper
la Palestine une décision accepté par le
peuple juif mais rejeté par le peuple
arabe VI de la décision deu à partager
la Palestine entre
juif
un partage forcé qui entraîne une guerre
civile et des morts 1067 arabes 769
juifs et 123 anglais selon les chiffres
britanniques entre novembre 1947 et
janvier
[Musique]
1948 mais malgré tout la décision de
l'ONU est entérinée et l'État d'Israël
est officiellement proclamé le 14 mai
1948 benourion qui n'avait cessé de
lutter pour imposer conception du destin
du peuple juif proclama la naissance de
l'État d'Israël une déclaration aussitôt
suivie d'une réaction des soldats
palestinien le 15 mai
1948 quelques heures seulement après la
naissance de l'État juif C armées arabes
s'enfoncent dans le territoire d'Israël
Jérusalem est
prise les Israéliens contre-attaquent
rapidement et repousse les Arabes
au-delà de leurs frontières quand le
conflit se termine en juillet 1949
Israël s'est agrandi d'un tiers en
s'appropriant une partie des terres
réservées au Palestiniens par le partage
de
[Musique]